[Música]
en Brasil a tres semanas de la segunda
vuelta que opondrá a la izquierda Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva contra el actual
mandatario yahirld sonaro los ataques se
hacen cada vez más personales y
explosivos lejos de la política
fue controlado el incendio en la isla de
Pascua que quemó más de 100 hectáreas de
territorio afectando varias almohadas
icónicas estatuas de piedra ubicadas en
el parque nacional la de rapa nui las
causas siguen bajo investigación
y miles de mujeres lideraron
manifestaciones en Estados Unidos o por
los derechos sexuales y reproductivos en
rechazo de la reciente anulación del
fallo roads a un mes de las elecciones
de medio término la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo es una prioridad
demócrata
Estas son las noticias de América en
France 24 comenzamos en Brasil la
hostilidad se intensifica entre los dos
candidatos a la Silla presidencial antes
de la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
del 30 de octubre canibalismo y
borrachera Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva y
Yair bolsonaro intercambiaron
acusaciones fulminantes este viernes los
dos se buscan convencer así a los
indecisos y al electorado del centro
mientras que las más recientes encuestas
se dan a Lula como vencedor con un corto
margen los detalles con la aurel
una misma estrategia atacar su
adversario en el terreno de la
personalidad le reinicio de la campaña
hacia la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales en Brasil
anuncia una intensificación de las
acusaciones entre los dos candidatos el
viernes el equipo de campaña del
expresidente izquierdista Luis Ignacio
luradas Silva difundió un antiguo video
en el que el actual presidente
ultraderechista Jair bolsonaro afirma
que es capaz de comer carne humana
porque es el quién da una declaración a
un periodista estadounidense y lo repite
Así que no es una invención no son
noticias falsas no es una maldad por
nuestra parte solo estamos informando a
la gente de quién es nuestro oponente
la entrevista que bolsonaro concedió al
New York Times en 2016 donde describe lo
que presenta como un ritual de la
comunidad indígena yendo mami se hizo
viral en las redes sociales el mismo día
Una otra secuencia marcó la campaña el
actual presidente que suele referirse a
Lula como ladrona lo califica ahora
también de alcohólico
si pones a un borracho al frente de
Brasil un tipo sin responsabilidades que
tiene un historial de corrupción un
historial de libertinaje hacia la
familia brasileña de ataques a
sacerdotes y pastores de ataques a las
fuerzas armadas de ataques a la policía
crees que funcionarán cierto
queda por ver si estas acusaciones
convencerán a los votantes indecisos a
tres semanas de la votación el último
sondeo de datafoliada a Lula como
ganador con un 53% de los votos frente
al 47% de bolso
en Chile las autoridades lograron
controlar un incendio en la isla de
Pascua que quemó más de 100 hectáreas de
pastizales y varias moais las icónicas
estatuas de piedra ubicadas en el parque
nacional rapa nui las causas de la
conflagración aún son desconocidas
mientras que los arqueólogos estudian el
daño real causado por las llamas Andrés
triviño nos cuenta más
desastre arqueológico en Chile un enorme
incendio forestal en la isla de Pascua
causó la pérdida de aproximadamente unos
80 moáis las icónicas estatuas de piedra
ubicadas en el parque nacional rapanui
en territorio insular chileno sobre el
océano Pacífico las autoridades
catalogaron el daño de las llamas como
irreparables
aproximadamente en un sector bastante
sensible de La Isla porque Presenta una
riqueza arqueológica que debe ser de las
más importantes tal vez de la Polinesia
también
arrasó mucho de patrimonio natural harto
de plantas nativas que todavía
permanecen en el lugar las llamas que
iniciaron el pasado lunes 3 de octubre
ya lograron ser controladas sin embargo
se desconocen las causas del incendio
pero las autoridades tienen la hipótesis
de que fue producto de malos manejos por
parte de ganaderos la isla de Pascua se
encuentra ubicada a 3.500 kilómetros del
continente americano y es habita por
aproximadamente 8.000 personas según las
autoridades arqueológicas La Isla
alberga unas 900 estatuas y más de 300
plataformas ceremoniales
realmente fue fue muy triste ver el el
daño causado por el fuego pero
lamentablemente
hubiéramos tenido la cantidad de gente
suficiente no hubiera sido capaz porque
las condiciones no estaban dadas para
trabajar la conflagración sucedió tan
solo dos meses después de que la isla
abriera de nuevo al público tras dos
años y medio de cierre total a causa de
la pandemia siendo el turismo en la
principal fuente de acceso económica
para sus habitantes
en México en el estado de Chiapas desde
el jueves se registran desplazamientos
de centenares de personas indígenas que
huyen de los enfrentamientos entre
grupos armados violencia que ha
adquirido especial dramatismo en otro
estado del sur Guerrero donde esta
semana fue asesinado un alcalde
municipal tiene más detalles de lluis
Muñoz
bajo la lluvia
[Aplausos]
llantos y oraciones estos indígenas
tzotzil lo han perdido todo
[Música]
los grupos armados se disputan 22
hectáreas de tierra en el municipio de
Santa Marta víctimas mortales y
desplazados que huyen de la violencia
tengo ganas de morir de miedo por eso
sali
mos ya se va a morir por por la balacera
no es hasta que no pasan los sucesos que
el estado se moviliza y hace presencia
las dinámicas del narcotráfico se
extienden por el antes Pacífico Sureño
estado de Chiapas ahora convertida en
territorio de producción y ruta de paso
para el comercio de droga por el
corredor del Pacífico también en el sur
en el Estado de Guerrero en San Miguel
totolapan esta semana al menos 20
personas murieron en una guerra
territorial entre cárteles el alcalde
fue asesinado el número 94 desde el año
2000 el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador culpa al legado recibido
son organizaciones
que vienen de tiempo atrás
no surgieron En este gobierno
desde 2006 cuando el estado lanzó su
lucha contra los cárteles de la droga
más de 340.000 personas han muerto en
México
las mujeres lideraron manifestaciones
multitudinarias en Washington DC y en
otras ciudades de Estados Unidos o por
los derechos sexuales y reproductivos
cada vez más limitados después de la
anulación del fallo robby hace poco más
de 100 días a un mes de las elecciones
de medio término en el país las
colectivas feministas se rechazaron de
nuevo el fallo de la Corte Suprema que
acabó con la protección al derecho al
aborto a nivel nacional el alto tribunal
dio vía libre a cada gobernación para
emitir sus propias leyes con respecto a
la interrupción del embarazo lo que se
ha traducido en restricciones en 13 de
los 50 estados del país para los
demócratas Este es un tema central de
campaña
durante 50 años hemos ido en la
dirección correcta con nuestros derechos
y de repente nos los quitan y nos los
van a seguir quitando
A menos que nos levantemos juntos y
luchemos por nuestros derechos y eso es
lo que necesitaremos con
las próximas elecciones de mitad de
término es de Vital importancia a
recordarle a la gente que salga y vote
para que de esta manera podamos
preservar nuestras libertades básicas y
codificar
con suerte codificar la igualdad
matrimonial y cualquier otro de los
demás
en otros temas de América Latina
retomamos la resolución de la
Organización de Estados Americanos oea
que este viernes en la asamblea aprobó
respaldar a la posición de Argentina
sobre las islas malvinas en poder de
Reino Unido el organismo llamó a una
solución pacífica y negociada más
temprano conversamos con Federico
Lawrence historiador y autor de varios
libros sobre el tema como la guerra por
las malvinas le preguntamos por qué esta
es una disputa de interés hemisférico Y
si la resolución no tiene relevancia más
allá de lo simbólico
bueno empiezo por el final la resolución
tiene una relevancia que
lamentablemente mientras el Reino Unido
permanezca intransigente orilla a lo
simbólico lo cual no quita que la
presencia británica en el archipiélago
de las malvinas sea una amenaza regional
y por eso el recurrente apoyo de loea en
un contexto de un mundo multipolar la
malvinas siguen siendo un puente para
amenazar o para ejercer control sobre el
continente sudamericano y también por su
proyección antártica con lo cual Es
lógico que los Estados Americanos
expresen su preocupación y pidan una
resolución ahora mientras no se muevan
los términos de la discusión si no sale
de los simbólico
hay más para ver
[Música]